Yeah,
I guess that's the problem of when you're like serializing a Monga every week.
I wonder how much of it like is actually planned before and how much of it just
feels like it's falling apart.
Which is why, like the more Mangar read,
the more I respect to something like one piece,
which can keep coherency this long, you know what I mean? And,
and it just continually getting continually and just continually getting better
and better. But I mean,
like that's also why I really value when a Monga just has a good ending,
not even a mango, but just any meat, any media in anime, Mongo,
light novels that just has an ending that people are satisfied with it.
I don't ask for much, but I do ask for a satisfactory ending.
I I've, I've just the more I've been reading Monga.
My pet peeve is like where it just starts to fall apart in the last 40 50
chapters that's been really, that's been happening a lot.
Ruins.
I feel like an experience of going through this entire long journey with these
characters that you fall in love within this wall,
but it is interesting for you to come to like a Olympic ending.
You know what I mean? Like there are like, I, I swear to God,
I can count the amount of like satisfying endings on like my hands in,
in that I've read in Mongo because there is like most of the manga that I love
are still ongoing, like classics, like bezerk, vagabonds,
Vineland saga, for example.
And then there are other things like slam dunk where you just feel, you know,
it just kind of, kind of just ended, you know what I mean? It had its,
you know what, come on you,
you can't say that that final chapter of slam dunk don't spoil it for me.
I want to read it. Okay. Well essentially,
like I'm not going to tell you how the story goes because it's a lot to unpack,
but basically like slam dunk.
I really liked the final chapter of slam dunk because it was kind of like
experimental almost because almost another dimension,
the basketball slam dunk, you know, because what,
what really made that like final chapter famous was the fact that almost the
entirety of the final chapter has no dialogue. Oh, that's cool.
And it's just like it, like basically he was just like,
let me just show you the story rather than telling you the story. I,
I don't have the problem with the final chapter. I just felt like,
like the wrap-up or I felt like they,
they could have gone further with the entire story and I feel like he just kind
of ran out of ideas and just kind of just ended it. You know what I mean?
But it's not that it wasn't a great final chapter. It was just that I,
I wanted to spend more time with these characters now.
I feel like that could have been room to spend more time and I'll go,
Oh, if we're talking about, if we're talking about absolute cuckold endings,
like [inaudible] go is a show. No, no, no,
not a go Mongo. It's it's.
Yeah. This one by the, well, in the ghost.
Yeah. The one where that goes, teachers doesn't end. Well, it just ends
in like a really controversial way where people were kind of just like,
wow,
there must've been some like strings behind the scenes that will kind of just
like, you're going to end it this way, whether you like it or not,
because it's very, very on satisfactory. Yeah. Nobody.
Was there any good endings that you can think of off the top of your heads,
aside from where you asked me to put into it?
I know you were about to mention her. You asked me,
I think of the most like genius ending. It's all to be put in place.
Yeah. I haven't read light many moderate compared to Jerry, but I don't know.
I'm happy enough if it just doesn't completely itself near the end. I honestly,
is that how it is that how it is to be man?
As long as it doesn't completely everything up. Yeah. I'll be okay.
Like average. I'm still satisfied with it. Yeah, exactly.
I just recently finished watching reading B stars.
Just the last volume came out like a week ago. Yeah.
Not the strongest ending in my opinion,
but it wasn't a complete show of an ending. So I was like, you know what?
I'm satisfied. Like, okay, could have been better,
but it could have been a lot worse as well. So.
Is the ending of a Mongo that important QV salsa music?
I feel like if an ending of a Monga or even an anime is good,
that can bring it up from like a,
from like a decent show to like a master. Yeah.
I mean, I mean the biggest example I can think of is the cluster.
That was code yellow season two. Yeah.
And yet somehow the like I will never forget it because of how great the
ending was. Same with something like cowboy bebop, for example, as well.
The ending matters more anatomy than it doesn't bond, I think is the difference.
I don't know. I think the way you linked lengthened,
the way that you experienced it,
I remember vastly the best bits for Monga more than I do.
Like I said, I, when I look back on Monga,
I remember it it's like an amalgamation of like the whole experience together as
opposed to episodes and like scenes and also, um,
yeah, so I just find that when I finish them. Yeah.
I'd rarely ever think about the ending of any of them.
I just think about my favorite moments really.
Um, I'm the complete opposite, I think with manga,
I think more about like certain scenes, whereas with anime,
I think about it kind of as a whole. Yeah. Yeah.
And I think maybe it's because I binge anime,
so I kind of experienced the animate all at once. Whereas with manga,
a lot of it, because it's rather long, like for me,
a couple of episodes I've binged both.
So I guess ending's always important to me,
especially if I've felt like I've spent like a lot of time with these
characters, like, like it doesn't have to be a,
it doesn't have to be like an amazing ending,
but what I want is a satisfying ending,
but if there's an ending that is actually amazing and sticks with me,
then I'll always remember that Mongo. It's true.
Because I read all of Finland saga, which is amazing. Yeah.
Up to the point where it was out like a few months ago. Yeah. And if I,
if I never read it again,
I probably be happy knowing that I had a good story up to where it,
or up to where I got to, which sounds weird.
Cause it like literally was in the middle of like a fight. I was like,
you know what? I've.
Read a lot. I've read, I've read so much of this.
That I'm actually satisfied if I just stop reading this Mongo, I'll be okay.
Yeah, I'm fine.
But I guess that's where the double-edged sword is. Right.
Is that the longer the mung it goes for the more greater of an ending you expect
almost, I guess sometimes, or sometimes you just, cause sometimes you are,
you've read a market for so long that you kind of just want it to end.
You can get hugged. You kind of just, cause that was me with narrow tone,
tells me with bleach, you know what I mean? Where they,
they got to a point when I was just like,
I am reading this purely because I've invested so much time and it it's,
it's it's, it's the league problem. Right. You're just like,
I've invested so much time in this that I just need to,
I just need to play it out. What would you say is the cap then you just know.
It's like a feeling, right? Like when I was reading ice shield,
I like when it goes to like chapter, like 250, I'm like, all right,
let's wrap it up. But it had like another a hundred left. I was like, all right.
I like, this felt like it went on long enough.
Like it felt like they were adding too many things.
Like a lot of mangrove had that wet.
Like what was once a gigantic threat earlier on?
They haven't changed much in power will suddenly be like, they dispatch it.
And like once one hit. Right. There's so many stuff like that where it's like,
so this really cool enemy you introduced,
you stopped just one shotting later on. Yeah.
It's like, what's the point of this?
Like you're just completely ruining all the steaks over and over again.
I hate it.